[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen nachgemacht und ein
grundrezept ich werde nämlich
marshmallow fleisch selber machen dass
es kein produkt was im supermarkt gibt
das gibt aber als original oft in der
amerikanischen abteilung marshmallows
love wird in amerika ganz oft und ganz
gerne als brotaufstrich verwendet oder
zum beispiel wie hierfür cupcakes als
torten füllung oder auf torten aufstrich
und torten creme ihr könnt es wirklich
ganz einfach selber zu hause nachmachen
ihr braucht dafür auch nur ganz wenige
zutaten und im prinzip ist es eine creme
aus eiweiß und zucker und das eiweiß
wird auch erhitzt so dass einfach die
keime abgetötet werden
ich zeige euch mal welche zutaten ich
verwende für smart spieler flach
verwende ich 100 gramm zucker 60 gramm
glukose 45 milliliter wasser 75 gramm
eiweiß eine prise salz zehn gramm zucker
und etwas wandel extrakt so heißt
nämlich jetzt den zugang der kommt in
einen topf und glucose kommt dazu
gemeinsam mit dem wasser und daraus wird
jetzt ein sirup gekocht und glucose
bekommt er natürlich online bei uns oder
auch in der apotheke und dadurch wird
das fleisch wirklich extrem gut ist
jedoch ist eine richtig klebrige masse
und dadurch erhält die super konsistenz
man kann es im prinzip auch ohne machen
und nutzer verwenden
aber so wird noch mal ein bisschen
besser
und ich lasse es jetzt bei mittlerer
hitze aufkochen und dann darf sie ein
paar minuten kochen bis auf 100 17 grad
erhitzt wird
ich nehme dafür dann ein zucker
thermometer falls ihr keines hat man
kann auch ein bisschen nach augenmaß
arbeiten ich zeige euch dann wird die
bürger bläschen aussehen in der
zwischenzeit kann ich aber schon mal das
eiweiß steif schlagen
das gebe ich jetzt hier mit rein da
solltet ihr natürlich darauf achten dass
es ganz frische eier sind die werden
zwar gleich erwärmt und die keime werden
getötet aber trotzdem nehme ich das mal
ganz frische bio eier da jetzt ein
bisschen salz nation und dann bei
mittlerer geschwindigkeit ganz langsam
steif schlagen wir wollen ja nicht dass
es zu steif geschlagen wird und soll
auch nicht zu trocken gerührt werden
und deswegen muss ich auch auf den sirup
achten
[Musik]
jetzt sind die bläschen ganz klein und
klar die temperatur ist es auch erreicht
und ich habe hier zum ice nach dem
restlichen zucker gegeben also die zehn
gramm und jetzt ist das eiweiß auch
bereits jetzt lasse ich in einem ganz
dünnen strahl denn sie rocker zu
schließen
jetzt sieht man auch gleich wie die
konsistent sich verändert habe und von
trocken- und flockig wirklich zu
geschmeidig und glatt wird jetzt muss
sich die creme einfach nur noch
plattform und kalt und es dauert jetzt
so etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
jetzt ist das flach fertig gerührt ihr
könnt sie jetzt zum beispiel verfeinern
mit etwas von elektra qt ich mag dieses
jetzt aber vor
ok ich weiß kaum zu glauben dass ich
keine vanilla verwende
aber ich möchte jetzt schneeweißen
schneeweiß lassen bei hassen habe ich
gesagt dass ich zeige euch jetzt mal ich
will es jetzt einen spritzbeutel also so
ist es auch schon ein richtig leckere
brotaufstriche protein ihr könnt auch
als torten creme verwenden ich hab's
auch schon verwendet um eine torte außen
zu bestreichen das sieht dann aus wie
richtiger schnee oder verwendet um zb
spuck cupcakes zu spritzen
da kann man dann auch später richtig
schöne show pia so druck machen wir bei
schaumküsse das spiel auf love ist dann
tatsächlich bei raumtemperatur drei bis
vier tage haltbar oder im kühlschrank
bis zu einer woche
guckt mal mit geschmeidig das aussieht
und so sehen die muffins hat wirklich
super cool aus schmeckt sehr lecker wie
gesagt können die vanille extrakt
zufügen zitronenschalen abrieb oder auch
andere aromen probiert es einfach mal
aus einfärben klappt auch super und das
rezept könnt ihr dann nochmal nachlesen
auf meinem blog auf salehs blog.de
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und wir
sehen uns wieder das nächste mal tschüss
[Musik]
das original sally marshmallow fluffy ab
sofort in jedem handel
[Musik]